The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
The last time
we talked a little bit
about Baumol's disease
and why it affects
products that are not
seeing technological
change that saves cost.
And not seeing
import substitution
that might reduce cost.
So they tend to grow at faster
than the rate of inflation.
And transit is one
of those activities.
And what happens is,
the public sector
ends up either taking
the responsibility
to provide those services,
or subsidizes private parties
to provide those services.
Other services
will die or there's
some combination of the two.
The services get
cut back, and then
some set of services that
are viewed as too important
to allow to disappear the
government subsidizes for.
what do you do about it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just curious, what
are some other things that you
consider subject
to this problem,
outside of public
transportation [INAUDIBLE]
like emergency
medical, like fire.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Well
certainly fire protection
services, police, teaching,
education generally,
the health care.
So what's the cost
problem in health care?
No technological change
going on in health care?
AUDIENCE: Nothing cost reducing.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
Nothing cost reducing.
A sneaky phrase that I put in
was cost reducing technology.
In health care, there's
a lot of technology,
but it generally
increases costs.
Once there's a better
way to deal with cancer,
we all want it for our
parents, our kids, ourselves.
So technology and health
care tends to drive costs up.
For maybe a good thing.
It means we're
getting more quality,
but from a cost point
of view, it's cost.
Yes.
The cynics think
that's a bad thing
because you cost more money.
Better you should die quickly
of some disease than hang around
and need more health care.
So it gets at some
philosophical questions.
But it's just from a
practical point of view.
Baumol's disease is
a serious problem
that affects public services.
And it particularly affects
public transit, which
is what we're interested here.
So I don't think we talked
about this last time.
So what did Baumol say happens
with an activity that's
afflicted by Baumol's
class disease?
AUDIENCE: To hire the people
who perform that activity,
they need to--
their salary needs to be
adjusted to inflation.
But you're essentially
paying them more and more
for producing the same amount.
That's where-- that goes
the musician example.
Because if you want
to hear live music,
paying musicians 100, 200
years goes the same thing.
You have to pay them.
You had to pay back
then, you pay today.
But today they pay rent
or whatever it is today.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
So what's the--
what's Baumol's
argument about how
you could continue to have
four string quartets performed
If you choose to?
You're going to subsidize them.
But what's the economic
rationale that he makes?
His argument is,
assuming there's
productivity improvement
in the economy overall,
the overall gross domestic
product is going up.
So you actually could
afford to subsidize
these activities, music, if
you had health care, whatever.
And you'd still have a
surplus because there's
been enough growth.
Since it's the-- since it's the
technological change that is
a factor in the
increased wages, then--
and here the theory is that in
the parts of the economy that
are experiencing introduction
of cost saving technologies,
labor will be able to
get pay increases higher
than the rate of
inflation, because they're
in a position to leverage
that growing productivity.
Are you with me on that?
So now, the worker
and industry A
that has productivity
improvements
gets pay increases beyond
the rate of inflation.
But if I'm trying
to hire bus drivers,
the bus driver
wants the same pay
because he's living in the
same metropolitan area,
paying the same rent.
So the bus driver wants to
get the same pay increases
that the worker in the more
highly productive sector
is getting.
So embedded within the
productivity improvement
is a wage increase.
Now there's a presumption
there that labor
does get a proportionate
share of the productivity
improvement.
Recently that has
not been happening.
For a long time that
appeared to be the case when
Baumol was writing.
So you end up with the
technologically advancing
sector needing to
pay higher wages.
The more stagnant
sectors needing
to pay comparable
salaries to attract labor,
because they're working
in the same market.
And therefore, larger and
larger subsidies in those
sectors where productivity
is not improving.
AUDIENCE: So a
couple of questions.
One, I guess this
assumes full employment.
If there wasn't full
employment, then you
would pay bus drivers less
than the more technologically
advanced employees.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Well it
assumes full employment would
be one way to think about it.
But if there's not
full employment,
but the workers are organized,
and in transit they're
very organized.
And they're able to command--
they're able to bargain
for higher wages
because they can make
the comparison to what
other workers make with
similar educational background.
And even though there are
unemployed people there,
because the union is able
to control the workplace
to some degree,
even full employment
isn't a necessary
condition for this problem
to occur and to grow.
AUDIENCE: Being organized is the
necessary condition [INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
I would argue being
organized is more
important than full employment.
AUDIENCE: And is that
because, the way I think about
is that because transport is
such an essential service?
For example, when
I was in London
the tube shut down like
15 times for strikes.
And the government is really
resistant to increasing wages,
giving into their demands.
But eventually they
have to because you're
losing a billions
dollars in the economy
or something like
that every time you
shut down the Tube for a day.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
So-- Yes, so it's the
practical consequences.
Labor has a lot of leverage.
And if you think about the
areas we're talking about,
they tend to be areas that
have a high labor content.
Or they wouldn't
be so vulnerable.
By the very-- it's
a circular logic.
They are vulnerable
to Baumol's disease
because they employ
a lot of local labor.
And the productivity
is not increasing
with technology change.
Therefore, they've
got a growing problem.
And the problem is compounded
because the workers being
numerous, and organized, are
able to get those higher pays.
So you're in a bit of a bind.
So what do you--
you can simply pay more.
But the other consequence
of having the government
into the subsidy business
is that other agendas then
accumulate.
If Mussolini is in
charge, then you
have to join the Fascist Party
or you're not allowed to sing.
If Obama is in charge or
some other elected official
that you like better
than Mussolini,
you're still going to get some
political exactions attached
to subsidy.
Because get-- the process
of getting subsidy
through a legislative process
gives people leverage.
And there's a
particular problem.
Why might the problem
be worse for transit
than it is, say for education?
Assume for the sake of
argument, education and transit
are similarly dominated
by local labor,
and similarly if afflicted
with Baumol's disease.
Why might the leverage
issue be different
in the legislative bodies?
AUDIENCE: In many
ways the teachers
are like [INAUDIBLE]
employees maybe more
than the bus driver
[INAUDIBLE] Is it
because education is
compulsory [INAUDIBLE]
probably why [INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
Well not so much that.
It's much more Universal.
Kids in Springfield
need to go to school.
Kids all over Massachusetts
North Adams and Pittsfield
don't require the same amount
of transit that the bus
metropolitan area does
because we're a
congested area, we've
got a certain kind of economy.
So there's a much higher
proportion, much higher
dependency on public
transportation
in a place like London,
or a place like Boston,
than there isn't a
place like North Adams.
So when you're going to
the legislature saying,
I need money to
subsidize the MBTA,
the legislator from
a district that
doesn't get much
service says well,
what are you going to give me?
So why should I vote for this
subsidy so people in Boston
can ride more convenient
transit at lower cost?
You've got give me something.
So the political process
imposes conditions
on the process of subsidy that
exacts a premium on top of what
Baumol would have predicted.
Baumol's analysis
was that it's all
about competition for labor.
And you're going to be
forced to pay the prevailing
wage in that metropolitan area
in order to attract labor,
because there are competing
opportunities for workers
to work.
Let's assume it's
full employment,
possibly it's because
of the leverage
in the workplace of the union.
But you're going to have to
pay that metropolitan area
competitive wage.
But what Baumol
isn't calculating
is that the very process
of getting subsidy out
of the political process
imposes these extra costs.
So this is all me
rambling theory.
So a couple of years--
AUDIENCE: Pure-hearted
politicians.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
Even with good politicians
that are really
trying to do the right thing,
they want to support transit.
They have to convince voters in
other parts of the state that
don't have much transit
to put money into it.
They've got to do
something different.
I mean, in Massachusetts for a
long time what Western Mass was
getting out of the
state government
was the University of
Massachusetts payroll.
Because UMass was located
out Amherst, there were jobs.
It was a very important
part of the economy
that's not very robust.
There were heavy subsidies
to higher public education.
Eastern Mass, in
an earlier period,
was much more dominated
by private universities.
Now there's a UMass Boston.
But in an early
period was really
all concentrated out there.
So the rough trade was, OK
you got the T, I got UMass.
But there is some price attached
by the political process
to providing subsidy.
Because in the more unevenly
spread the service is,
the higher that
price is going to be.
That's me making up theory
and asking you to believe it.
So a couple of
years ago, a couple
of times in the
past few decades,
I've been lucky enough to have
a lot of very smart students
doing their masters degrees.
So I've inflicted Baumol's
disease on a couple of them.
So [INAUDIBLE],, I'm going to
mangle his name, [INAUDIBLE]..
Have you guys read
his work at all?
He is a brilliant
guy from Jordan.
Very interesting fellow.
He did a really nice
piece on Baumol's disease,
and somewhat theoretical piece.
And showed, yes, it looks
like transit really has it.
Then a couple of
years ago, there
was another student
named Javier.
I think some of you knew Javier.
So he got-- he did
an analysis where
he looked at a large dataset.
I think he looked at something
like 700 transit agencies.
And he was just looking at bus
services in the United States.
And he found that the MBTA has
Baumol's disease, number one.
Number two, every bus
provider in the United States
has Baumol's disease.
It's not unique to the T.
We think the T is worse,
it's actually not.
It's a problem everywhere.
Number three, there is
a premium above what
Baumol would have predicted.
Baumol would have predicted
this metropolitan area
comparable wage.
But in fact transit wages
are raising perversely, not
only higher than
inflation, but higher
than the salaries of
comparably skilled workers
in the same metropolitan area.
And the only explanation
I could figure out
is the leverage of the
legislative process.
We've got two kinds of leverage,
the leverage of the workers
in the union
bargaining position.
But then you got the
leverage of other legislators
who insist on some
additional price to be paid.
But you've got labor
also commanding power
in the legislative process.
So now, if I'm
running the T and I
need to go to the
legislature to get money,
the theory is that I'm
the boss and there's
this sort of structure and
these workers work for me.
The fact is, the
workers have way
more power than I do in
talking to the legislature,
because the union
has a lot of voters.
And they're disciplined, and
they can deliver that vote.
And they can deliver
workers, and they can
deliver campaign contribution.
And I'm trying to
peddle public policy,
and transit is good for
you, and you should do this.
So I really need
labor as an ally
in getting the support of the
legislature for the subsidy.
And, perversely, labor figures
that out and demands even more.
So sounds weird,
but Javier's data
shows this is
absolutely the case.
That there is a premium
above and beyond
what Baumol would
have predicted.
And it's all over
the United States.
Then he took another look.
And we made up a couple of
tests of what might an indicator
be of the relative
political strength of labor
in a state or a
local jurisdiction.
So do any of you know what
the right to work laws are?
So what's a right to work law?
AUDIENCE: It's a
law that [INAUDIBLE]
they're laws that
basically prevent
a union from requiring
employees in a given industry
to join a union.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
So the right wingers
who don't like
unions, that's all right
wingers don't like unions.
They're very clever
at making up names
so it's called
the right to work,
because that sounds
kind of nice.
But it's also from
if you're pro union,
it means that the union
has to convince workers
to join the union.
They collect dues.
They have to-- it costs
money to organize and develop
an agenda, and lobby, et cetera
And if not everyone in the
group has to join the union,
then you've got a free rider
problem where people can say,
oh, I'm a libertarian, I don't
believe in unions' bullshit.
Well, they want you give
back half of your pay.
You're enjoying the benefits
of having union representation,
but you just don't
want to pay your share.
I'm giving the unions
point of view obviously.
So are the what--
AUDIENCE: I said
or you're Ayn Rand.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Oh, OK.
So anyway, you get--
so you get this situation
where we hypothesized that--
right to work laws passed
in a lot of states,
and didn't pass in
a lot of states.
And they did not pass
and states surprisingly,
that have strong unions.
And they did pass in
the South and in places
where they weren't, where there
wasn't much political power
on union side.
So we said, well, maybe that's
a proxy for the political power
of unions.
So have Javier took the right to
work states, separated them out
from the states where union
membership is a requirement.
And lo and behold, yes
there's a bigger premium
on top of Baumol in the states
that are more union culture.
And the states that are
more anti-union in culture,
there's less of a
premium being paid.
So it looks from the
data like this guess
as to what's going on is at
least consistent with what
the data says.
Javier you added a couple
of nice papers on it.
So then the next question
is, so what do you,
what do you do about this?
AUDIENCE: So is
there anything else
that's like the government
when they give jobs
wants to give good paying jobs?
Is like a part of it.
Not just how to get votes from
the bus drivers themselves,
but from other people.
But the government's
always trying
to-- like this whole election
was won on creating jobs.
I know these are
government jobs.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
Well for politicians
who get their
votes from workers,
there's more of a desire
to be a good employer.
But it's actually inconvenient
to have a subset of workers
who are largely financed through
subsidy, making higher wages,
and with better health
care and pension benefits
than other workers who
are paying the taxes.
So it actually creates a
division within the workers,
that why the hell is this
guy getting more than me.
And I'm paying his salary.
And so it's not
particularly convenient,
even for a somewhat
left-wing politician
to want to pay higher
pays, other than the fact
that especially if they're
from a district that
has a lot of bus
drivers, then they
want to take care of
that constituency.
So there's the kind of
client-based politics
that drives some politicians
in that direction.
But a sort of general
left leaning attitude
wouldn't particularly argue
to pay transit workers higher
than teachers.
But transit workers make
more money than teachers.
So I mean it's a
pretty weird situation.
And you keep peeling
away the onion
saying what's really
going on here.
And it looks like A, Baumol's
disease is a real problem.
And B, there is this premium
on top of Baumol's disease
that comes out of the nature
of the political process,
and the extra bargaining
that labor has.
So labor has bargaining of the
normal kind that a union always
has with an employer,
because they
control the supply of labor.
But then it has this
political dimension.
So once the enterprise becomes
dependent on political support
for subsidy, labor now
has to bite of the apple.
And I think it makes
sense as a theory.
Looks like the data supported
it from Javier's research.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So transport
[INAUDIBLE] teachers
[INAUDIBLE] at least to what
Scott said about the fact
that transit the
TFL goes on strike,
then the London economy
loses a billion a day.
When transit agencies, when
their labor goes on strike,
the economic pain
that they create
is immediate versus teachers.
If our kids aren't being
educated, then the impact
we'll be seeing only 10
to 20 years down the line.
So with transit
the economic pain
is they have more [INAUDIBLE].
It's not, its leverage and
its immediate economic impact.
That's why the unions
exist [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's why
transit [INAUDIBLE]
if transit workers
go on strike, but you
don't go on strike in the summer
when people can walk to work.
And let's face it, [INAUDIBLE]
go on strike in the winter when
the weather [INAUDIBLE].
The same reason that garbage
men go on strike in the summer,
is because if they go
on strike in the winter,
the garbage piles up, and
freezes, and no one smells it.
But if they go on
strike in the summer,
they use that kind of logic.
It's the same kind of leverage.
It has more of an
immediate effect.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
So [INAUDIBLE]
was also advising out here on
his thesis and on the papers
that he wrote on this.
So [INAUDIBLE] said well,
let's take a look at whether--
I mean one way to try to
counter Baumol disease would
be to become more productive.
After all, this disease
comes because of a lack
of productivity growth.
Shouldn't we look at
improving productivity first?
Is transit performing at the
efficiency frontier in the way
they're employing
their resources.
So a bunch of more
analysis is done.
And, of course, transit
isn't operating anywhere
near its efficiency.
So it's a question.
It's important to look at it.
And as managers, if you end up
as managers in transit systems,
you certainly have to
pay a lot of attention
to looking for ways to
produce better quality
public transportation
at lower cost.
I believe that it's more
fruitful to look to get better
quality for similar cost.
The current management
to the T thinks
that it's a victory to give
you the same crappy service,
but spend less money doing it.
I don't think that's
all that good.
The objective is
not to reduce costs.
The objective is to improve
what you're offering people,
I think.
If you want your product
to be prized, and still
around in 10 years,
as opposed to just
being a temporary Band-Aid.
But there are different
philosophies of management.
But in either case,
whether you're
looking at a cost
reduction type strategy,
or whether you're looking
at a value maximization,
productivity and efficiency are
important things to look to.
So that's such one kind
of thing you should
be involved in all the time.
And you could also
think about what
are the external factors that
might lead transit to become
more valuable over time.
Even if you're not being
particularly more efficient
in the way you're delivering it.
So if the metropolitan
area is growing,
and if transit is also
growing, then the cost
per rider or the subsidy
provider should go down.
Because you've got less empty
seats, that's the nice version.
You've got more crowded buses,
the not so nice version.
But you can get
more service, if you
don't look too hard at the
quality of that service,
at lower cost as the system
gets more and more customers.
So growth in passengers
is certainly benign.
Now too much of a good
thing is a bad thing.
You get the kind of crowding
you're studying in Chicago.
That doesn't seem quite
efficient when people can't of
get on, and are being left
behind, and everything else.
But from the point of view
of the green eyeshade guys,
that are just looking at
the numbers, the more people
you cram onto the vehicles
that's dampening down
the subsidy a bit.
So even with no particular
management, effort, or skill,
if the region happens
to be growing,
and if transit ridership
happens to be growing,
then the value of the
transit is growing.
And that can offset the
Baumol's problem to some degree.
And if you think of what
the competing mode is.
If the area is growing
and the jobs are growing,
and the congestion on
the roadways are growing,
conditions that certainly
apply here and in Chicago.
Then the societal
value of the transit
is higher, both for
the riders because
their alternative choice
is to be in the congestion.
And for the drivers
who don't use transit
who are in the
congested conditions who
are happy to have some
people out of their way.
So through no virtue
of the transit manager,
if the regions are growing
and ridership is growing,
that can help offset
the Baumol's disease.
Both in the practical sense
of getting more revenue,
and in the theoretical sense
that the value of the transit
collective product
is actually going up,
through no virtue of your own.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE] they're
growing about 100,000 people
a year.
I'm just wondering whether when
that's happening, when they're
not opening any new tube lines
essentially, there's one,
well one big line
coming in soon.
But they're not any
new lines lines.
Everything's getting
more and more crowded.
It's actually hard to get on.
Almost there's a way to-- and
it's not politically very good
way to raise taxes, especially
during peak [INAUDIBLE]
things like that, to actually
allow people to get on.
And then you almost have
reverse Baumol's disease
because the value
has gotten so high.
And the alternatives are
[INAUDIBLE] in the tube ride.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
So it would have to be pretty
extreme to actually totally
offset the Baumol problem.
But it's certainly an offset.
And that's-- none of you
guys are going to rat me out,
are you?
This thing is being
taped isn't it?
AUDIENCE: Maybe an eighth of us.
[INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Well,
we've got our visitors from TFL
coming tomorrow.
And they they're great people.
And it's a very
competent organization.
And they're very
proud of themselves
for running a good service.
And they, in fact,
for a long time
were able to persuade
two different mayors.
One, the labor mayor
red Ken Livingstone
the Trotskyite, and then
the right wing conservative
mayor Boris.
And they were able to convince
the Trotskyite, as well
as the conservative
that it was OK to try
to increase transit fares by
the rate of inflation plus 1%.
That's a pretty steep,
especially for a labor
kind of mayor.
The current mayor
is a socialist,
and he's not into
seeing that continue.
And I don't blame him.
But TFL was really happy
that they had this strategy.
And of course they
argued that well, we're
providing better service.
So people should pay
for that better service.
And to some degree that's true.
And their numbers were
looking very good.
But it turned out that
the population of London
had grown in the previous five
years, more than anyone knew.
So there was a secret assist
to the numbers coming out
of the fact that the
population had just grown,
along with a growing economy.
And not to take anything away
from a very competent bunch
of people running TFL, they
were in the right place
at the right time.
You bunt on third base and
think you hit a triple.
Here we are.
You're in London with
this terrific system,
and the economy is growing,
and it's kind of going up.
Now it's a little unfair
because they are very competent,
and they're doing a good job,
and they work hard at it.
But a lot of it is just luck
of being in the right place
at the right time.
So there's an external
extra benefit to transit
that can help offset Baumol's
disease in those cities that
are growing.
So what do you do in a
city that's not growing?
What do you do in North Adams?
What do you do when General
Electric pulls out a Pittsfield
yanking 5,000 jobs with them?
You know you don't have that
luck in those situations.
So it's nice to be
lucky, but you can't bank
on that in a systematic way.
And you need to be able to
sort of look at the situation
and think that through.
So another place you
might get funding support,
and this is very hard to do,
and they successfully did this
to some degree in London.
Is to try to secure
funding support, at least
political support, from
those growth constituencies.
So the easy thing to do, not
easy, all of this is tough.
But the relatively
feasible thing to do
is to identify the
beneficiaries of what
you're doing, above
and beyond those people
riding on the system.
So you look at what's going on.
And you say, hey, there's a much
real estate developers making
a lot of money.
And they couldn't develop those
densities except for transit.
So let me go to them and try to
get them to politically support
taxes that someone else
will pay so that there
can be better transit.
That's the easier lift, right?
Let's increase the sales tax.
Real estate developers don't
pay particularly more sales tax
than other people do.
Everybody tries to do things
with other people's money.
So I can make a
campaign contribution,
raise the sales tax, have
a better transit system,
my real estate value
goes up, I make money.
That's one proposition.
That doesn't happen
automatically.
It's hard to do,
but it's doable.
A more significant,
more significant
achievement was what transport
for London pulled off
on the funding of Crossrail.
Because they went to the
financial services community
that really wanted
Crossrail because they see--
they've learned a little
bit from the experience
that when Docklands
light rail got built,
all of a sudden these Docklands
that were kind of abandoned
start to be successful, and too
successful, and hard to get to.
And then they do the Jubilee
line, and another growth spurt,
and wow.
The economy's
growing, this is good.
Now let's do Crossrail.
We're going to really
get a massive amount
of additional crosstown
capacity, very
large investment.
It's two big digs.
It's like we use the Big Dig
as a unit of measurement,
that's about $25 billion, I
think it's $25 billion pounds.
Does that sound right?
AUDIENCE: I just
know it's a lot.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
It's a big, big deal.
So how are you going
to fund that thing?
Well, let's go to the
national governments
and say hey, give us some money.
This is virtuous.
Here's our benefit
cost analysis.
Look how wonderful it is.
And the national government
say, get out of here.
We've got a political problem,
too much going to London.
Lots of parts of the UK
that aren't so successful.
They're not very sympathetic,
so forget about it.
What they end up at
the end of the story
without going through
the various attempts,
is they convinced--
they put together a package
that has three components.
One, they pledged to defray a
third of the costs of Crossrail
by continually increasing
transit revenues.
That can be through
more riders, or it
can be the same riders
at higher fares,
or a combination of the two.
But a third of the
capital cost is
going to come out of the
riders because they're
going to be beneficiaries
of less crowded conditions,
and more convenient service.
A third of it will get
from the government.
And a third of it
we're going to put
a surcharge on the real
estate tax of large companies
in London, on the
commercial real estate.
Not the little corner
store, but anything
bigger than some minimum.
Now that's a hard ask.
Because now you're saying
to someone, admit it,
you're a beneficiary,
and you should
be willing to actually put some
of your money on the table.
And they're never going
to agree with you because
of the ethical argument.
It's the practical
argument look,
we can ask for 100 percent
national money all we want,
they're never going to do it.
We've got to have
something different.
So they put together this a
third, a third, a third package
and they succeeded.
Now, the national government
is the most fraudulent
of the three parties.
Because if you think
of the, and this
was true with the
alleged labor government
then even more true
with the conservatives.
What's the marginal rate of
income taxation in the UK right
now?
AUDIENCE: Well it depends
on what bracket you're in,
but the highest bracket is
45% above 150,000 pounds.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
OK, and what if you're
say 80,000, 50,000 pounds?
AUDIENCE: You pay like a
marginal rate of like 30%.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: OK 30%.
So [INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah so 30%.
So we're going to
build Crossrail.
This is an unusual burst
of construction activity.
We're going to import a bunch of
Polish workers to do the work.
They're going to leave their
wives and kids back home
in Poland, getting
educated back there.
They're going to live
on marginal conditions
where they are, and the
national governments taking 30%
off the top of what they make.
Maybe more than 30%.
So this one third that
the national government
contributed, they're
getting it all back
from what they're taking out
of that blip in employment
that the project is causing.
So they're the most
fraudulent of the three.
They're not really
contributing, but boy they
made them crawl through a
sewer pipe to get the money.
But the point is,
you need to identify
who the beneficiaries are.
And, at the very least, you
need to enlist their support
to get someone
else to pay taxes.
And you may not
get away with that.
So you may have to do something
to make the constituency
that benefits put some of
their own money on the table.
And the analog on
that in Boston would
be, it's very nice to get
federal and state money
to upgrade transit services.
But that's state
money is coming out
of parts of the state that
are much less affluent.
So why shouldn't Boston and
Cambridge and Somerville
put some money into
both the operation
and maintenance of the service.
Seems to me, there's an ethical
argument that they ought to.
And there's a stronger political
argument that they better,
because the rest of
the state's not going
to pay for Boston anymore.
Boston's doing too well
economically to expect sympathy
from the rest of
the state on paying
for the investment
in the services
that the Boston
economy requires.
So the point is,
if you're trying
to deal with the Baumol problem,
and you are, you can be lucky
and that's nice.
And you should at
least recognize
that you're being lucky.
But then you also have to say
who are the beneficiaries?
If I make up this fancy
externality argument
that it's good for society
for there to be more transit,
there must be some real
human beings in back
of that external benefit.
I better figure
out who they are.
And at the very least, get
them to support me politically,
and preferably even willing
to put some of their own money
on the table.
So it's kind of a thought
process to go through.
Another strategy that is
often, maybe to greater degree
described as a panacea, and that
is well, let's contract out.
These unions are,
not to be pejorative,
they're just too
good at what they do.
It's not that they
are nasty people.
That they've got leverage,
and they're using it.
They think that's their job.
They're getting more wages and
benefits for their employees.
So why would you be surprised.
But you're having
a real problem.
So if you contract out,
maybe you won't pay as much
of a Baumol premium.
Now, deconstruct
what I just said.
Do you buy that?
What if we contracted out
all the bus service for the T
to third party?
So Paul Revere could
run everything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] So you'd
have to bribe them somehow.
You can't have-- you couldn't
have one private service when
the whole thing, because
they'd just unionized
to the private service.
Unless there was some
kind of right to work law
that was passed [INAUDIBLE]
in Massachusetts.
So you'd have to like contract
it out to 30 agencies.
And they would also all have
to have a different union
[INAUDIBLE] random.
Rather than all joining some
one Transit Workers Union.
I don't think there's any, now
thinking it out, any way you
could force them to do that.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
So you're saying
if you can't do that it's
of no value to contract out?
AUDIENCE: I don't
think it's of no value,
but I think it's
of marginal value.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
Anybody want to argue?
You got a little more
than that out of it?
AUDIENCE: I think
I know we're going.
But still hopefully
this is [INAUDIBLE]
that you can sort of by
contracting some of it out,
you can have a check on
the power of the unions.
And sort of what
you're saying is
that you can have sort
of two systems that
keep each other in line
with one system [INAUDIBLE]..
I guess the problem, like
the problem with unions
is they're often not
necessarily based on the company
you work for.
They're often based
on a type of trade.
So you could end up
having two companies that
run bus services,
but actually they all
destroy the bus [INAUDIBLE]
And it's quite possible
that in the short-term
you might have more competition
than longer-term [INAUDIBLE]
basically [INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
So is this competition
you're trying to get,
is this all competition
among rival workers?
AUDIENCE: No.
[INAUDIBLE] between
[INAUDIBLE] work [INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
The companies are going
to make profit on this.
So it's not just the employees.
It's also the private companies.
So Javier runs the numbers.
And looks at well,
let's see there
are a bunch of places
in the United States
that do contract
out for service.
And let's see if services that
are contracted out cost less.
Now, before I tell
you what he found,
what would you expect to find?
A, how many of you
think you would expect
to find that it costs
less to contract out
than to do it all in-house?
AUDIENCE: Is this across all
state the same labor law?
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Do you--
all states.
And we're just talking buses.
We're not confusing
it with rail,
which is every city is
a little bit different.
It's just bus drivers.
AUDIENCE: I'll go
with [INAUDIBLE]..
Cost less.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Costs less.
Anybody disagree?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think it has more.
I think it probably
costs way more.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Cost
more to contract out?
That's interesting.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because once you
contract it out, you have--
you don't want to
bring it back in-house.
And potentially in a
lot of these markets
you don't actually
have competition.
You have one player.
So that one player you'd
be subsidizing more,
potentially pay more rent
to the employer rather than
the employees.
Because that one employer has
a lot of leverage over you
to drive up the amount
you get paid overtime.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
So that's very insightful.
And that's fairly accurate.
What the data shows that
Javier pulled together
is that contracting out
does reduce cost somewhat.
But that in comparison to places
that provide all bus service
with in-house employees.
But that the cost performance
is consistently better
in those places that do a
combination of contracting out
and in-house.
And that's probably partly
because once the contractors
figure out you don't know how
to do it yourself anymore.
They get you over a barrel.
And they take advantage
of the leverage.
And it's partly because
you can't manage something
if you don't know how
to do it yourself.
So when you're contracting
out, the transit manager
has to know how to
manage that contract.
And if you're not doing anything
in-house that's a weakness.
So that indicates that the mixed
strategy seems better than all
of one or all of the other.
But if you had to
choose, you might
choose for the
contracted model based
on the way the numbers look.
But the half and half or
the part that, some of each,
seems to be a better strategy.
AUDIENCE: Is it also the case
that maybe some services are
going to be run more
efficiently by contractors,
whereas some services can be
run more efficiently in-house?
Plus it makes sense
to contract out
when those services that can be
done more efficiently that way.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: It's
possible, but I don't think so.
I mean a bad, and
unscrupulous manager,
or a set of
unscrupulous employees
could, for example,
look at a bus
route that is not very full.
But there's a policy
headway that says well
even if the bus isn't
full we should not
provide less than a bus every
15 minutes in this corridor.
An unscrupulous manager or an
unscrupulous union might say,
all these people will fit in a
bus every 30 minutes, screw it.
We're just going to
run half the service.
And if they don't get caught
they'll pocket the money
if it's a contractor.
And if it's the workers,
they'll just play cards and not
run half the routes.
In Puerto Rico when we were
doing work there the story was,
I don't know if
you have verified.
Discovery was one for
me, one for the company.
The schedule says there's
a bus every 15 minutes,
we run one every 30 minutes.
That's good enough, and we
play dominoes in between.
Have you heard the story?
AUDIENCE: Well when I consulted
for them and with [INAUDIBLE]
that was the case [INAUDIBLE]
The reality is that they didn't
have the buses to operate,
no buses in good condition.
So they only had half the fleet.
So we couldn't pull
out [INAUDIBLE] Sot
it ended up being what you said.
[INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: So
anyway what I'm saying,
though, is that
you could view it
as a kind of corrupt
practice by a contractor.
Or you could view it as an
unethical practice by workers.
But there's leverage in a market
where policy wants a better
level of service than
the service requires
in market terms.
There aren't enough
people paying fares.
Because you lose
some riders when you
mistreat your riders that way.
But if your fares
are low, and you're
mostly dependent on
subsidy, then your customer,
if you will, whether
you are employees
or whether you're a
company, your customer
is the agency paying
you with subsidy.
Your customer is
not the rider who's
paying a fare to get a service.
So you've changed the dynamic of
who your institution is trying
to please in its behavior.
And workers aren't particularly
better than companies
in exploiting
situations like that.
It happens both ways.
So the theory is that you
won't get the benefits
unless there is competition
among different companies.
If you go to
private contracting.
Even if you only do
partial contracting.
You look at the
data and say well,
I'm not going to
make that mistake.
I'm going to do some.
You still would like to
have multiple companies.
Well, in some areas there
aren't multiple companies.
You can't just will
them into existence.
And if your objective
in the competition
is to minimize the amount
you're paying in subsidy,
you may make this such
a marginal business
that it's quite unattractive
for people to come into it.
So if you've got a strategy to
control Baumol's disease based
on contracting out, you can't
be excessively cost conscious
or you will destroy
the incentive
for people to be part of it.
So you've got to think
about why you're doing it.
Now, if you're
doing it to improve
the quality of the service,
and to provide more service,
then you may be able to have a
growing business opportunity.
So that more companies will
want to come into the area
because it looks like a
good place to do business.
But if it's a kind of
stable, 10 years from now
is the same number
of riders is today,
it's a pretty dead end business.
So you're not going to really
get top managers trying
to provide better
service for less money,
either in the public sector
or when you contract out.
But there's a more
fundamental theoretical thing.
And I'm going on too
long about Baumol.
But what's the maximum
you would expect
to get out of a strategy of
contracting out and getting
competition?
Would you totally offset
the Baumol's disease?
AUDIENCE: Just delay.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: So why
are you saying no, Leo?
AUDIENCE: Because [INAUDIBLE]
People [INAUDIBLE]
That's the way I feel
[INAUDIBLE] actually brings
a lot of the fighting
between the two parties.
You have to realize that
they don't [INAUDIBLE]..
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: There's
some of that but there's
a more fundamental issue.
The theory that
Baumol put forward
is that in order
to attract labor
you're going to have
to pay the prevailing
wage in the metropolitan area.
And therefore, you
are stuck with costs
to grow faster than
the rate of inflation.
You can have all the
competition in the world.
It's not going to change the
prevailing wage in a Baumol
disease industry.
You are going to have
to pay the Baumol
premium that Baumol identified.
What you may escape
is the premium
on top of Baumol that
Javier identified,
which is coming out of
the political leverage.
As opposed to the
workplace leverage
that unions and contractors
have in the legislature
on affecting the--
So you shouldn't,
theoretically, expect no matter
how skillful you are
with contracting out,
no matter how much
competition you get,
you will still need to pay
something like the prevailing
wage or you won't have workers.
If you pay too little,
you'll get workers
with very bad habits, who don't
show up on Monday because they
went drinking over the weekend.
And you start providing
a lousy service.
So you are stuck with the
problem that Baumol identified.
What you may reduce
is the premium
on top of that that comes from
the political complication,
the political power of
labor, and companies
in the legislative process that
is providing the subsidy, which
is essential to deal with it.
The first practical question
for Baumol's disease industry
is where are you going
to get the money?
You need the subsidy.
And then the process
for getting it
has these other complications.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So basically
you're saying
it's the government
themselves that
pay the subsidy to the
contractor to induce them
to participate in the market?
Because basically
the private companies
aren't subject to
Baumol's disease
because they wouldn't take the
contractor to do the business,
unless the government
pays them [INAUDIBLE]
counteract Baumol's disease.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Right.
So even if there's
lots of competition,
and there are 10
different companies,
they're not going
to bid below what
it's going to cost them
to offer the service.
They're going to have to
pay the prevailing wage.
So don't be surprised
over a decade when
you see that that's
gone up faster
than the rate of inflation.
If you should define
success as being,
if you would
maintain that growth
at or below the
rate of inflation,
in the prevailing wage, then
you're doing something right.
Now, if simultaneously
the region is growing,
so are these external benefits.
And you're able to actually
charge more for the service
as they have been at
transport for London,
then you may actually
begin to offset
even that part of the problem
that Baumol identified.
But the point is
that contracting out
is an interesting strategy,
but it's not a panacea.
It's unlikely to get you
below the Baumol threshold,
so to speak.
But it may get you--
it may help you reduce this
premium that you'd otherwise
be condemned to pay.
So this diagram is
just a way of saying
once you're running a
business subsidized,
your organization chart
is really complicated.
I mean in Massachusetts
you've got a governor,
the Secretary of Transportation
serves at the pleasure
of the governor.
There's a board of directors.
There's a general manager.
In some, just within
Massachusetts,
there have been times when
the general managers served
at the pleasure of the governor.
There have been other times
when the general managers
at a contract from the board.
So if you've got a
situation where there's
a secretary, a board, and
the general manager, now
who's the boss?
Is that the secretary?
Is it the board?
That general manager then has to
manage this production system.
Has to worry about customers.
Has to worry about fares.
But he's got to deal with labor.
Needs support for the taxes.
Who controls that?
Congress, the legislature?
Labors got more access
to those sources of power
than the management
structure does.
The governor who's supposed
to be on top of all of this,
he may be from a different
party than the legislature.
Legislature may not even like
the guy, so he's not much use.
What's going to get you
votes in the legislature
for some law that's going to
help you run a better transit
system?
It might be capital
to buy new buses.
Might be just the
operating subsidy.
Labor's a big piece of this.
So you've got to recognize
the kind of power
and influence they're
going to have.
So let's talk about the
history of the labor movement.
Talked last time a little
bit about the commons union,
the eight hour day.
What's the story with
immigrants and labor?
We all holding hands,
singing solidarity forever,
American-born immigrants
all loving each other?
AUDIENCE: Immigrants always
get the scraps of work.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
Yes, immigrants
are the last ones in.
So whoever is the earlier group
tends to dominate the jobs.
Tend to dominate the
management structure.
Tends to dominate the power
positions within the union.
So there's not this--
there's not real solidarity
within the union.
You get factions
And the newest immigrants
are usually underrepresented,
sometimes dramatically
so by the union.
We had a situation at the
T, where through a fluke
we were able to hire
part-time workers.
This piece of
legislation went through.
And the pay scale for the
part-time workers without it
was outrageously
low, and did not
include health care benefits.
Well, I was really offended.
I said, we're a public agency.
We're treating these
people horribly.
And we don't want
them to hate us.
I would hate us if I
had to work these hours
without a decent pay,
without health care benefits.
Let's at least pay
health care benefits.
Union says no,
you can't do that.
You can't confer a benefit
except through the bargaining
process.
Oh, well surely you agree
that your dues paying members
should have health
care benefits.
Nope, we don't care.
You're taking their dues.
You're supposed
to represent them.
Nope.
You're going to have
to give us something
if you want us to allow
you to pay benefits
to those part-time employees.
I mean you'd like
to strangle them,
but there are rules
to bargaining, and so
[INAUDIBLE] that are
all about leverage,
and very little
about public policy.
And your first expectation
about how people will behave
is very often not the case.
There are these sort
of perverse incentives.
And the first preoccupation
on the Union side
is usually to get re-elected.
And the more
democratic the union--
do you think
democratic unions are
better than autocratic unions?
How many people vote
for democratic unions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain the difference?
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
Democratic union
is one where there are
elections every couple of years.
And often the
president of the Union
loses, and a new
president comes in.
And there's a real give
and take and debate.
So in the autocratic
union there's
a family that's been the
president and business
agent for the past 25 years.
And when the old man gets
old, his nephew gets the job.
So you got both kinds
of unions around here.
Which one do you
think is preferable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] better
for the workers or profit
[INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
Well, either.
Take it separately.
Better for the workers.
AUDIENCE: Just because
you're asking the question
I'm going to go with autocrat.
I think it's a tie.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes,
well the democratic union--
the union is-- the
union leader is
so afraid he'll lose
the next election,
he won't make any decisions.
So we, at one point,
had hired smart people
like John Attanucci
to figure out
better ways of producing stuff.
And they run these
numbers and say,
hey, we can structure the
work for the rail side
into four 10 hour
days, a 40 hour week.
People will get long weekends.
We can make the numbers work.
It'll save us money,
and the employees
will make the same money
and have three day weekends.
And they sort of
test it with people,
and the workers
really like this idea.
Union wouldn't accept it,
because they were afraid
that it would become an issue.
So you couldn't even
give them something
that you knew the workers wanted
because they were so weak.
They were afraid to make a deal.
You get a more autocratic
union, and there
are some not so nice
things about the autocrats,
but they're willing
to make a deal.
They know they're going
to be president next year.
They've got enough confidence
they're going to get reelected,
that they're better able
to step back and say,
well, what's the long view here.
And they may be exercising
that power, on a good day,
they're exercising that power
on behalf of the workers.
But they're not so
hypersensitive to a faction
that they're unwilling
to make a deal.
In the dynamic of
the union, the union
is just like any
other organization.
The people who count are
the people who show up.
So you have a union meeting
once a month, who shows up?
A small subset of people.
Everybody else--
Everyone else is
out bowling or watching
television, or doing
whatever they like to do.
They don't go to union meetings.
So you got to take
care of the ones who
show up at the meetings, because
that's the attentive public.
They're the ones that
are paying attention.
So the dynamic within the union
may appear to be democratic,
but it's also dominated
by small factions
whose interests may diverge
from that of the larger group.
And especially if there has
been a period of ethnic change.
Typically, the dominant
group in the union
reflects the ethnic
composition of 25 years ago.
And the smarter ones realize
that they better pay attention
to the new workers,
or they're going
to lose their
positions more quickly.
But the nastier ones just
say, the hell with it.
I'm going to take
care of my people,
and I don't care about them.
So democracy is a mixed
blessing sometimes.
But it always makes it
interesting and complicated.
Go to Item H because we're
running out of time here.
World War II labor shortages,
wage and price control.
Do any of you know the
story of the World War II
wage and price controls?
What was going on then?
AUDIENCE: Wages were frozen.
Yes.
So consumption of
products was also frozen.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes,
because the government was--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] war.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes, and
the government was afraid of,
that the shortages would
lead to price spikes,
and there'd a huge
political backlash.
So they put in wage
and price controls.
So the industries that were
producing, particularly
for the war effort,
because that's
where the was a lot
of money to be made,
needed to attract workers.
But they couldn't offer
higher wages under the rules.
They started offering
health care benefits.
It was the only way
they could compete.
At the end of the war, some of
the socialist labor leaders,
Walter Reuther and
others, looking
at what was going
on in Europe said,
well, this is a stupid
way to fund health care.
Let's have health
care for everybody,
and let's do it in an
across the board way.
And the big businesses said
no, we like it this way,
because this gives us an
advantage that our workers are
getting health benefits,
and the other aren't.
And that's to our benefit.
So these bastards who yap about
out-of-control health care
costs, the reason we've got
this backward system we've got
is because of their greed,
and their unwillingness
in the post-world War II
environment, when you really
could have gotten a much
broader base Medicare
for all kind of approach.
They didn't want it that way.
Now they complain
that they're paying.
And I don't blame
them for complaining.
The system now,
it's kind of weird.
But it was a product of
the peculiar politics
of that point in time.
And you also do
get, theoretically,
it's possible that
labor unions might
like the idea that only
union members get health care
benefits.
And that they're not conferred
on the whole population,
because it's another
reason to join the union.
Fortunately the unions
aren't that narrow.
And they tend to be a
little bit more progressive.
But they're acting against
their own interests, in a sense.
It does confer some
advantage on them
if health care has
to be bargained for.
It's a reason to join a union,
and be active in the union.
So you get all these
perverse incentives that
come out of this kind of stuff.
We talked about right
to work a little bit.
So item C, ridership growth
is never instantaneous.
The point that [INAUDIBLE]
made earlier in the class.
A lot of important things
take time to achieve.
You don't instantaneously
get a benefit.
If you provide more service,
and you guessed right,
maybe there'll be a
ridership growth in the area
that you're providing
more service.
But it doesn't happen
the day you start.
It's going to take
time to build.
And that time
period, and the lag
with which-- even if you get
really well and a lot of riders
come, and you generate
a lot more revenue,
that revenue is going to
come later than the cost
that you have to
expend early on.
So you get this sort of
swerve in your pattern.
Now, this is a
couple of years old,
but unfortunately
it's still true.
There's this sort
of nasty attitude
that well, we've got
to grind down costs.
We've got to grind down costs.
We've got to grind on costs.
But the only reason we
have a transit system
here is it actually happens to
be important to the economy.
And we're lucky that
the economy's growing.
We actually need more service.
So to me, it's more important
to provide more service
than it is to grind down
the cost of the service.
If the only thing you're doing
is quote "saving money," then
shut the system down
and save all the money.
Presumably, you're
around because you're
providing something of value.
And you ought to be providing
higher value, and more of it,
up to some reasonable limit.
But certainly I
don't think anyone
who rides the T
would argue we've
reached the level where there's
too much service out there.
We've got a long way to go
in improving service to get
anywhere near to such a danger.
This brings me back to this
question of contracting out.
Because to me, most of the
discussion about contracting
out, if you're reading the
Boston papers, is about,
oh we'll contract out
and we'll save money.
And labor costs too much,
and blah, blah, blah.
In the first place, you're
not going to save much money.
The workers-- Paul
Revere, the company
that runs the blue M2 bus
that you see on Mass Avenue,
they're also a union operation.
They've got the Teamsters Union.
They provide health
care benefits.
They pay decently.
It's not about-- a good, private
contracting scheme in my view,
is not about paying
workers less.
It's about providing
a better service.
How many of you use
the number one bus?
And are any of you able
to use the M2 shuttle?
OK, which one comes
first usually?
AUDIENCE: M2, the one
depending on the day.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Which one--
which one are you more
likely to find a seat on?
AUDIENCE: M2.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: The
M2 is a better service.
That's what you could get.
That's not because the T
is inherently inferior.
There is not enough
service on that line.
But Paul Revere runs
a reasonable service
because, if they don't, they
won't get chosen next time.
There is some competition, not
just for cost, but for quality.
And to me, you want
to be in that area.
And the other issue is if
you want to increase service,
and you talk to the
MBTA, you go to a meeting
and say the service is lousy.
We want more bus service
on the number one bus.
And the answer is, fine
what service would you
suggest we cut so we can reroute
those buses onto the number
one?
We'll cut the
baloney, that's crazy.
Those other routes
need the service too.
They're in this
sum zero game where
they refuse to add service
except by taking away.
Consequently they
never add service.
And they said, well,
it's a tough world.
We only get so much equipment.
We only got so much drivers.
We only have so many
maintenance facilities,
land of 1,000 excuses.
We can't expand.
You want more service,
contract for it.
Put some money on the table.
Have a bid, work and
get some competition
so it isn't just Paul Revere.
You'll get more
service a hell of a lot
faster than you
will ever get it out
of the public sector machine.
So I think there's a pro rider
argument for contracting out
that I believe is quite valid.
But no one makes that.
You have this kind of contest
between the anti-cost,
grind down workers, it's a
victory if we pay people less.
And the union that says,
do everything in-house.
Neither of those
parties is really
speaking on behalf
of the riding public.
So you want to think
about those aspects.
Usually people talk about
the union relationship
as bargaining for--
union wants higher wages.
Management wants lower
wages, et cetera, et cetera.
Bargaining takes
place periodically.
You might have a
two year contract,
you might have a
three year contract.
You set the terms in wages
and working conditions
for that period.
Then you bargain again.
If you can't reach
agreement, there
are procedures for
binding arbitration.
Why do we have
binding arbitration?
Why don't we just have a strike?
You know?
AUDIENCE: Why do
we find [INAUDIBLE]
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
At the MBTA we have
binding arbitration.
It's not the case in every
transit agency in the country.
In Philadelphia if they
can't reach agreement,
there's a strike.
AUDIENCE: They put
it in state law.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes, why
was it put into the state law?
AUDIENCE: To avoid strike.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes.
So in Massachusetts the
thing was, wait a minute,
strikes are really
painful for everybody.
Let's just have a
bureaucratic process
to settle disputes
that can't be resolved,
but let's not have a strike.
Too many people are hurt
when you have a strike.
The workers-- workers lose
their health care benefits.
I mean, your kid's
got a kidney problem,
and you have no health
care, that's a problem.
So it's a problem for the
worker to be on strike.
It's not easy.
It's a problem for the
public, there's no service.
So binding arbitration
I think is a good idea.
There are those who argue the
Philadelphia system is better.
I think it's wacky.
They shut down the city
every periodically.
AUDIENCE: They lose
their health insurance
when they go on strike?
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Yes, if
you're not employed anymore
you lose the benefit.
AUDIENCE: But when
you're on strike
aren't you still employed?
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: Not
if the contracts run out.
I mean it's like,
it's a bizarre world.
AUDIENCE: But in most
[INAUDIBLE] is that going to be
the issue, because
if they have--
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: No.
Yes, in other places you would
have a more civilized way
of dealing with it, because you
didn't have this odd World War
II.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: The English have
way more strikes than we do.
Maybe that's because they're
not [INAUDIBLE] health
care when they go on strike.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI:
That could be true.
But they also--
I don't know if those are legal
strikes or illegal strikes.
Because sometimes
in Massachusetts
even though we've got
binding arbitration,
and it's against
the law to strike,
occasionally they'll walk out.
And it's very dramatic.
You put the labor
leaders in jail,
and that gets them
more votes next time,
because it shows how committed
they were to the cause.
A lot of theater involved
But the only point is the
drama is around the bargaining.
And potential strike, wildcat
strike, binding arbitration.
And it's about how much
money in the envelope.
But at least as important as
what's bargained explicitly,
is the day to day relationship
between management and labor
between the bargaining,
because you've got a job to do.
You've got to run service.
And there are
these arcane rules.
And the rules are so arcane that
if you comply with every rule,
you can't run the service.
Oh I'm not going to drive the
bus because the windshield
wiper is broken, and the
rulebook says I can't drive it.
But it's sunny out.
It's not raining.
We'll fix it tonight.
Nope, I'm not going
to drive the bus.
It's not in perfect condition.
So there's always an
informal relationship
between the employer
and the employee,
or the management
and the employee.
And that day to
day relationship is
very critical to the quality
of service you can provide.
And the papers never
talk about that aspect
of the Labor-Management
relationship.
It's almost always
about the bargaining,
and how much is in the paycheck,
and what the health care
benefits are.
So you really need to think
about the quote unquote
"culture of the place," and what
it's like to actually provide
service in a union environment.
And if you didn't
have a union, you'd
still have to solve the
problem of how to get--
how to motivate your workers.
So it's not-- the union is just
giving you an articulated forum
to deal with this issue,
which can actually
be kind of convenient.
If you don't have
a union, you almost
need to invent one because you
need some basis to communicate
with your workers
about, OK, how we're
going to get this thing done.
So if you shift your focus from
the paycheck bargaining aspect
to the management of the
production of the work,
I think you'll be looking at
the more important problem.
And I'm out of time
in two minutes.
So let's see if there's
anything else in here.
Here, how many of
you have seen this?
OK so what is it?
AUDIENCE: They've been
trying to do a few things.
Trying to get a increase state
income tax by a little bit,
particularly on the rich.
And they're trying to
get some more money out
than what the state provides in
transit, education, and health
care.
Or in this case, in transit.
FREDERICK SALVUCCI: And so
they're putting a lot of energy
into this.
And it's a direct--
the union has gained, in
my view, a lot of leverage.
Because the management at the
MBTA has been so into we're
going to privatize
this to save money.
We can do it cheaper
by contracting it out.
They never talk about
we can improve service
by contracting it out.
So they've totally,
in my view, blown it
because all they're doing is
saying we can do it cheaper
if we contract out.
And they've left
the playing field
open to labor to pose as
the champion of the riders.
And say, oh we are
friendly transit providers.
Give us more money and you
can have better service.
Never dealing with the fact that
the service production at the T
is pretty bad.
And the Paul Revere, private
companies, do a better job.
They are closer to that
efficiency frontier
that [INAUDIBLE]
was talking about
of getting as much
quality service as you can
out of a given resource base.
It's always possible to
get less than you paid for.
It's rare that you can get
more than you paid for.
That discussion never
happens that there's
a reason for contracting out.
Because we can grow faster,
we can provide better service.
So the playing
field has been left
totally open to labor
who says management
doesn't care about you.
They don't care how
crowded your bus is.
lousy the service is.
They're just into
being mean to labor.
I mean that's basically--
I think it's a
really dumb strategy
by the current
management at the T.
That's a very
objective statement.
And it's a minute late so, sorry
to go on too long and thanks
for being here.